bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 19 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour un nouveau
numéro de fileco votre rendez-vous
d'information sur l'actualité économique
locale avec aujourd'hui une émission
spéciale consacrée aux artisans et à
l'artisanat je vous propose de découvrir
le sommaire avec les titres de cette
édition
c'est la Semaine nationale de
l'artisanat jusqu'à dimanche les
artisans sont mises à l'honneur pour
l'occasion la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des Yvelines à organiser
différentes initiatives ne voulaient
présenterons cette semaine nous
intéressons au métier de prothésiste
dentaire un métier d'artisanat qui met
son art au service de votre sourire
enfin l'entreprise de la semaine était à
Magny-les-Hameaux l'art straiter prépare
des pièces de prestige pour des
événements de toutes sortes nous sommes
allés en coulisses et découvrir les
cuisines de ce traiteur local enfin dans
notre entretien de cette semaine nous
parlerons de la semaine de l'artisanat
nous recevons Stéphane Lévesque bonjour
vous êtes le président de l'Union
Professionnelle artisanale
d'Île-de-France vous répondrai donc à
nos questions sur la semaine de
l'artisanat et des artisans ce sera
l'occasion de faire un point sur leur
situation en ce début d'année 2015
n'avant cela passe en revue l'actualité
économique de la semaine
le club face fondation pour agir contre
l'exclusion organise différente
initiatives à destinations des jeunes
afin de favoriser leur orientation et de
faciliter lorsque la réalité et leur
rentrée sur le marché du travail mardi
une journée d'action appelée classement
d'entreprise était organisée en
partenariat avec l'entreprise EDF et des
élèves de 3e du collège d'un collège de
Magny-les-Hameaux pardon regardez ce
portage réalisé avec William elle
c'est 14 élèves de 3e du collège Albert
Einstein de Magny-les-Hameaux ne sont
pas dans leur salle de classe habituelle
ils suivent des cours au siège du réseau
de RDF à Montigny-le-Bretonneux faire se
rencontrer les élèves et le monde
professionnel c'est la mission que ces
données le club face avec l'action
classe en entreprise le but des cours
c'est pour montrer que les matières qui
s'apprennent à l'école bah ça peut être
important pour certains métiers donc là
on a choisi les matières assez
techniques c'est à dire technologie
physique-chimie et mathématiques par
rapport au métier
lié à l'électricité par rapport à la RDF
exercice du jour calculer la section de
câbles en fonction de son intensité pour
mettre en évidence la nécessité de
passer en haute tension une leçon au
programme de troisième là c'est vraiment
de transport de l'électricité donc on va
voir les pertes on va voir comment
fonctionne un transformateur pourquoi on
choisit certains câbles et pas d'autres
comment on fait RDF du coup pour
transporter l'électricité dans une bonne
condition et avoir des conditions de
transport qui soit optimales mettre en
pratique la théorie pour intéresser les
collégiens mais aussi leur faire
découvrir les différentes orientations
pour accéder à ces métiers de
l'électricité auquel il ne pense pas
forcément c'est vraiment une bonne
filière une bonne initiative de de nous
avoir amenés ici pour vraiment découvrir
cette ce secteur là pour la voie
professionnelle je connaissais vraiment
rien de cette entreprise et c'est
peut-être une voie vers laquelle je veux
je pourrais m'orienter je sais pas
encore quoi faire l'année prochaine en
fait certains élèves sont là pour
découvrir d'autres le savent déjà ils
choisiront une filière professionnelle
ou en alternance une voix très prisée
des recruteurs qui sont aussi dans la
construction de leur parcours en seconde
ils vont aller aussi sur des formations
générales donc c'est aussi faire un
petit peu germer cette idée que le monde
industriel et notamment sur les sur les
jeunes filles dans cette classe il y a
deux jeunes filles donc si on peut
susciter des envies le pari est gagné
favoriser une orientation réfléchie un
enjeu clé pour les élèves l'année
dernière 24 collégiens avaient participé
à cette première édition de classe en
entreprise
depuis la création du club face près de
3000 élèves ont été sensibilisés à la
découverte du monde professionnel
et je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière vendredi dernier la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de Versailles
Yvelines avait organisé un nouveau
rendez-vous pour les entrepreneurs
Express Eco un petit déjeuner
d'information destiné aux entrepreneurs
yvinois l'objectif répondre à leurs
interrogations et échanger autour d'un
thème la première édition était
consacrée au financement de nombreux
chefs d'entreprises sont venus afin
d'obtenir des informations sur le projet
sur leurs projets écoutez ces précisions
recueillies par Mélanie Pauquet je suis
en face donc de création d'entreprise
sur sur un sujet technique et puis j'ai
besoin au moment même de
premier coup de crayon du projet d'être
au clair sur sur les problématiques de
financement combien on peut obtenir
comment pour pouvoir ensuite à dessiner
un projet qui soit qui soit réalisable à
qui toujours en étant pertinent soit
réalisable et à m'apporter ma portée
financière lorsqu'on connaissait points
forts et ses points faibles on est en
position d'aller négocier avec son
banquier ou un investisseur quelconque
aujourd'hui se connaître c'est la
première étape avant d'aller chercher du
financement les autres points clés c'est
vraiment c'est les fameux ratio je suis
en fort développement est-ce que j'ai
les fonds propres nécessaires pour
accompagner la croissance de mon
entreprise je suis en face de création
est-ce que j'ai les fonds nécessaires ou
pas et les personnes aller voir est-ce
que j'ai besoin de prédonneurs pour
avoir cet effet de levier ou pas et être
surtout accompagné par des
professionnels et parlons maintenant
bâtiment et construction la société
Colas Île de France Normandie
spécialiste de la construction route
vient de prendre livraison d'un nouveau
bâtiment de 6850 m² à Magny-les-Hameaux
destiné à accueillir entre autres son
siège social ce nouveau bâtiment se
situe près du campus scientifique et
technique du groupe COLAS premier centre
mondial privé de recherche et
développement dans le domaine des routes
où travaille 80 employés au total ce
sont donc 350 salariés qui travailleront
sur le site de Magny-les-Hameaux
et je vous le disais en titre depuis
lundi et jusqu'à dimanche c'est la
Semaine nationale de l'artisanat le but
faire connaître aux jeunes et à leur
famille au créateurs ou aux repreneurs
les 250 métiers de l'artisanat mais
aussi encourager ce modèle d'entreprise
c'est dans ce cadre que la Chambre des
Métiers et de l'Artisanat des Yvelines
organisés différentes initiatives que je
vous propose de découvrir regarder ces
images liées oui Amel et Patrick de
Dixmude
1 2 3 on est dans la boîte les jeunes
artisans à l'honneur ils sont 56 anciens
élèves de CFA et Vinois être distinguées
tout sont reçu la médaille de bronze de
la formation artisanale une façon de
saluer leur parcours exemplaire comme
celui de Thomas il est chef de partie
pâtissier jeune artisan il a 5 diplômes
poches dont deux CAP et un brevet
technique des métiers il est fier
d'avoir choisi cette filière quand je
rigole avec des amis qui sont médecins
Jordy que j'ai à peu près le même
doctorat que sauf que c'est en
pâtisserie si on veut faire de la
pâtisserie de la cuisine de la
carrosserie ou d'autres choses c'est
vraiment le meilleur moyen d'apprendre
les écoles sont très bien pour apprendre
et il vaut mieux être dans le vif du
sujet pour voir réellement comment ça se
passe et avec des maîtres
d'apprentissage qui connaissent bien
leur métier on peut très très bien
évoluer en France ils sont près de 170
000 jeunes apprentis dans les Yvelines
près de 10000 élèves fréquents qui 60
établissements qui proposent des
formations en apprentissage à la fin de
leurs études en moyenne 85% d'entre eux
trouvent un emploi jeune qui rentre chez
nous la maison du travail ils ont on
apprend un métier et derrière ça ils
auront du travail et même si ce troncent
de parcours parce que ça arrive ils
apprennent néanmoins à savoir être un
savoir des devoirs de base qui leur
serviront tout au long de leur vie
artisan le métier d'une vie mais aussi
l'objet de reconversion afin de les
accompagner la Chambre des Métiers et
d'artisanat des Yvelines proposaient
également une journée de conférence et
d'échanges destinés aux dirigeants de
moins de 3 ans d'ancienneté cette
septième édition met en avant
l'importance du réseau relationnel pour
développer son entreprise
des artisans s'entretien établis à ceux
qui sont déjà établis professeur pour
montrer des jeunes qui tiennent devant
son vocalaborateurs tout le monde a un
réseau et après faut juste en avoir
conscience et les artisans ils sont
également à titre personnel sur Facebook
ou leurs enfants le sont ou même l'ont
été et donc c'est simplement parce que
le réseau ce n'est pas que facebook les
réseaux sociaux c'est à une démarche de
la vie de tous les jours et donc non les
artisans sont parfaitement au fait de
cela la différence peut-être c'est que
ils ont moins conscience des outils qui
existent mais ils ont tout le savoir
faire pour pour réussir utiliser les
réseaux pour se développer la France
compte 1,1 millions d'entreprises
artisanales dont la majorité sont de
taille modeste avec moins de 15 salariés
les artisans ont un potentiel réseau
important mais souvent sous-exploité
c'est très réussi je trouve voilà ça m'a
ouvert les yeux sur beaucoup de choses
et je vois plus vers où mes dirigeons
maintenant c'est quelque chose qui est
assez nouveau et très très important
faut pas négliger ça donc c'est quelque
chose on n'est pas conscient de ça alors
que ça reste basique pourtant redonner
un coup de jeune à l'artisanat c'est
aussi un des objectifs de cette semaine
avec 2,7 millions d'actifs l'artisanat
est la première entreprise de France
dans les Yvelines ils sont près de 30
000 soit près de 7% des travailleurs du
département
et nous continuons à parler de
l'artisanat des artisans avec notre
invité c'est l'heure de l'entretien de
la semaine
l'UPA et l'organisation nationale
représentative de l'artisanat et du
commerce de proximité elle rassemble 55
fédérations professionnelles nationales
en plateau avec nous Stéphane évêque son
président
Île-de-France alors bonsoir l'artisanat
concerne 2,7 millions d'actifs et 170
000 apprentis dans les Yvelines en 2013
ont compté 18512 entreprises artisanales
ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un peu
l'UPR qu'est-ce qui quel est son action
par rapport à ça ben écoutez les
chiffres sont déjà très bons donc mes
félicitations oui voilà donc je voulais
vous présenter l'UPR UPA tout le monde
ne connaît pas c'est principalement
l'Union Professionnelle de l'artisanat
l'UPR comporte trois familles la CGAD
donc qui compte qui comporte 16 branches
la CNAMS qui comporte 90 branches et la
CAPEP qui en comporte 34 alors quand je
dis CAPEB c'est tout ce qui est bâtiment
CNAM c'est tout ce qui est métier de
service taxi cordonnier et la CGAD c'est
tout ce qui est métier alimentaire
pâtissier boulanger
relative glacier etc etc et quel est
votre rôle par rapport à la Chambre des
mystères scène assez différent c'est
deux fonctions alors non c'est pas
différent puisque la Chambre des Métiers
et de l'Artisanat des Yvelines et gérer
par un président qui est ua qui est
Daniel Varlet donc c'est quelqu'un de
mon organisation syndicale non c'est on
travaille ensemble de toute manière
l'UPR travaille avec la Chambre des
Métiers puisqu'on travaille aussi sur
l'apprentissage et l'apprentissage
travaille aussi avec la chambre des
métiers en tant qu'organisation
représentative combien d'entreprises
défendez-vous en France mais aussi dans
les Yvelines alors sur le plan national
on défend plus d'un million 100
entreprises et sur le plan
Île-de-France c'est 179000 les Yvelines
bon c'est un petit peu moins vous avez
donné les chiffres tout à l'heure l'UPA
c'est c'est tout ce qui est artisan je
veux dire c'est beaucoup d'entreprises
vous avez des gens qui travaillent avec
un seul employé ou qui travaille des
fois tout seul moyenne 2 de salariés de
salariés voilà mais vous pouvez aussi
avoir des artisans qui sont tout seuls
dans leur entreprise donc effectivement
ça fait beaucoup de monde je vous
rappelle que l'UPR est la plus grande
entreprise de France c'est celle qui
embauche le plus de personnes et
justement ils sont beaucoup ils étaient
beaucoup le lundi 9 mars à manifester
contre le régime social des indépendants
vous n'avez pas appelé à soutenir cette
manifestation pourquoi oui alors le
régime social des indépendants on va pas
faire un grand discours là-dessus parce
que c'est très compliqué le RSI et la
protection sociale des commerçants
indépendants ça a été mis en oeuvre par
le gouvernement il y a ça quelques
années ça a été très peu préparé et
aujourd'hui si vous voulez le régime
social des indépendants est complètement
saturé avec avec énormément de retard et
aujourd'hui ça crée un certain nombre de
problèmes aux artisans ça les met même
en difficulté aujourd'hui puisque
l'artisan par rapport à celui qui est
salarié paye ses cotisations avec plus
d'un an et demi de retard et si vous
voulez aujourd'hui autant vous pouvez
avoir une aujourd'hui que dans un an et
demi vous ne savez pas quel trésor vous
avez voilà c'est très difficile de
prévoir et le RSI qui fait son travail
je veux pas du tout attaquer cette
organisation mais des artisans dans de
très grosses difficultés le problème des
artisans aujourd'hui c'est plus un
problème de charge c'est ça de charge à
l'arrière qui a s'acquitter oui alors
c'est ce que défend l'UPR national et ce
matin j'étais en réunion avec le
président national puisqu'il a convoqué
l'ensemble des présidents régionaux oui
on se bat si vous voulez dans toutes les
manifestations les quelques
manifestations qu'on a fait sur la
baisse des charges et aussi sur
une certaine révision de la
réglementation la réglementation dans
nos métiers devient trop dur trop dur
dans tous les points donc c'est
justement ce qui vous gêne par rapport
au fait de prendre des apprentis c'est
ça qui est trop lourd bien sûr prendre
des apprentis alors dans un premier
temps mais prendre aussi des stagiaires
parce que si vous voulez l'apprenti
avant de vouloir faire notre métier où
son métier il vient faire des stages
avant
on a on a des demandes de stage qui sont
six mois huit mois 9 mois avant qui sont
des conventions avec l'établissement
scolaire et c'est pareil je veux dire ce
sont des des conventions qui sont très
cadrées qui sont d'abord cadrées par
l'Éducation nationale donc je vous
explique pas comment c'est vous vous
connaissez un petit peu le système de
l'éducation nationale et ça ne reflète
pas notre métier notre métier moi je
vais vous prendre un exemple je suis je
suis pâtissier
la pose du jeune doit être entre 10h et
10h15 mais peut-être que le mardi on
fera une pause entre 10h et 10h15 mais
le mercredi on la fera peut-être pas
parce que à 10h on aura mis trois
plaques de croissants il faudra bien les
sortir donc si vous voulez trop de
réglementation c'est plus possible il
faut réduire la réglementation et
surtout alléger les charges parce que
les charges quand vous avez un apprenti
effectivement vous êtes exonéré de
charge mais quand vous avez un employé
vous n'êtes pas exonéré de charge et
c'est ça qui coûte à l'entreprise et
justement l'occasion de voilà de la
semaine d'artisanale ce sont des métiers
qu'on en avant on a besoin de dans
l'artisanat qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de leur dire pour justement qui
viennent et qui n'hésitent pas à
s'engager dans cette filière qui est
quand même porteuse d'avenir vu que 85%
à des jeunes qui qui si engagent
finalement trouver un emploi à leur
sortie ecoutez moi ce que j'ai envie de
leur dire c'est de venir faire notre
beau métier nos beaux métiers parce que
tous les métiers de l'artisanat sont des
beaux métiers et que il y a de l'avenir
dans ce métier aujourd'hui vous avez un
certain nombre d'artisans qui
travaillent très tard parce que les
artisans travaillent des fois jusqu'à 65
70 ans qui voudrait bien céder leur
entreprise mais derrière il y a personne
pour les reprendre et ça c'est moi ce
que je souhaite effectivement c'est
qu'on forme un maximum de jeunes que nos
CFA soient plein ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui malheureusement on a besoin
d'apprenti on a besoin on a des talents
il y a des jeunes qui aiment vraiment ce
qu'ils font il y a des jeunes qui aiment
leur métier et je crois qu'il faut
vraiment leur donner l'envie de le faire
pour pouvoir derrière reprendre nos
entreprises tout le monde est capable de
prendre une entreprise quand vous avez
quelque chose de génial dans les mains
et justement donc qui peut-être
n'osent pas encore se lancer dans
l'artisanat ou peut-être hésite quels
sont les dispositions qu'on devrait
mettre en place pour peut-être faciliter
cet accès peut-être ouvrir ce qu'on fait
déjà beaucoup de campagnes de
communication sur l'artisanat qu'est-ce
qui manque un petit peu pour justement
voilà faire en sorte que plus de jeunes
se dirigent vers cette filière moi je
dirais en fait qu'est-ce qui manque il
manque un certain nombre de
d'informations je pense qu'on ne les
informe pas assez sur le métier il y a
des portes ouvertes ce week-end il y a
une porte ouverte au CFA de Versailles
qui est juste à côté de la chambre des
métiers il faut que les jeunes viennent
voir comment ça se passe dans les CFA il
faut que les jeunes viennent voir
comment ça se passe dans les entreprises
mais il faut pas il faut pas tout cadrer
faut rester faut qu'ils veulent faire
faut qu'ils aient envie de faire ce
qu'ils ont donc si vous voulez moi je
pense que il faut ouvrir aux jeunes il
faut ouvrir les portes ne pas hésiter à
ce qu'ils viennent se renseigner leur
faire des présentations et je suis
certain que les artisans les
accueilleront vraiment les bras ouverts
justement les artisans les accueillent à
part ouvert c'est une façon aussi de
valoriser à l'économie locale le tissu
économique locale en mettant des jeunes
artisanat ah oui tout à fait bien sûr on
a besoin une jeune de toute manière nos
entreprises ont besoin de de de telles
nouvelles et ont besoin de jeunes parce
que les jeunes ont des idées je veux
dire on a il y a quelques jours nous
avons récompensé les jeunes talents au
Grand Rex il y avait plus de
90 jeunes qui ont été récompensés sont
des jeunes entre 18 et 23 ans mais
c'était formidable ce qui se faisait
c'était vraiment de toute beauté donc
oui il faut absolument les les pousser
il y a pas de problème un dernier mot
sur les Yvelines est-ce que nous avons
une station spécifique dans l'artisanat
dans les Yvelines quel secteur peut-être
s'en sort le mieux attire plus de jeunes
non je pense qu'il y a pas de situation
spécifique
je dirais que pour les jeunes tout est
bon alors c'est sûr qu'un jeune se
mettre à moins taxi que peut-être
pâtissier ou que peut-être maçon tous
les métiers dans les Yvelines sont là il
y a énormément de formateurs
et je vous rappelle qu'on a de beaux CFA
un CFA aussi qui qui a de la place avec
avec des très bons professeurs et je
pense que maintenant il faut juste
qu'ils viennent se présenter et j'espère
qu'il y aura un maximum de contrats
d'apprentissage pour la rentrée
prochaine et bien le message est passé
merci Stéphane évêque d'être venu sur
notre plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et nous continuons sur la
artisanat pardon avec le chiffre de la
semaine assez tout de suite
4,3 milliards d'euros c'est le chiffre
d'affaires généré par les entreprises
artisanales du département ces données
viennent de la Chambre des Métiers et
d'artisanat des Yvelines en 2012 elle a
recensé près de 17 6 entreprises
artisanales il faut savoir que près de
33245 salariés ivinois travaillent dans
ce secteur et que chaque année on
recense environ 2000 nouvelles
entreprises artisanales créées dans le
département
et nous restons avec le métier de
artisanat avec des métiers de bouche
c'est pour l'entreprise de la semaine
et oui je vous disais nous restons dans
l'artisanat avec des métiers de bouche
avec l'entreprise l'art streter c'est
une entreprise installée à
Magny-les-Hameaux depuis 1976 elle
organise des événements des mariages sur
notre territoire et aussi en
Île-de-France reportage dans les
coulisses de cette cuisine de renom
dans les cuisines les petites minces
affaires il est 9h du matin dans le
laboratoire de l'art traiteur le coup de
feu est déjà passé mais il reste encore
de nombreuses pièces des cocktails des
entremets ou encore de la pâtisserie à
réaliser
l'âme de cette cuisine c'est le chef
Michel Frot présent depuis les débuts de
l'aventure en 1976 il suit de près tout
ce qui se passe dans les cuisines de la
cuisson des viandes aux verrines on a
surtout un collectif sur le principe
c'est pas de laisser la pâtisserie d'un
côté ou la cuisine froide de l'autre au
sein du traiteur c'est terminé ce bon là
c'est elle n'existe plus c'est un
collectif
une quarantaine de personnes travaillent
à plein temps dans l'entreprise elle
embauche ponctuellement des employés en
plus pour pallier les besoins lors de
grands événements la retraiteur organise
près de 150 mariages chaque année en
plus de l'événementiel pour les
entreprises une charge de travail plus
importante et très différente de celle
d'un restaurateur traditionnel la
différence entre le traiteur et le
restaurateur c'est que la carte est
ouverte en permanence on n'est pas
soumis à 30 produits ou 40 produits
c'est à dire que la carte cocktail ici
représente à peu près 250 pièces la
carte comme je veux dire la carte de
plat chaud on peut potentiellement faire
plus de 200 plats chauds et on a toutes
les cuisines du monde représentative
c'est à chaque client vient avec sa
demande spécifique et on y répond
certifié qualitraiteur le travail fait
maison et relève de l'artisanat chaque
jour près de 200 plateaux repas sont
livrés et quelques 4000 pièces de
cocktails sucrées ou salés sortent de
ces cuisines selon les événements tout
est rigoureusement vérifié avant de
partir en livraison de
réaliser des pièces de prestige en
grande quantité un savoir-faire conservé
en 2005 lorsque l'entreprise a changé de
propriétaire racheté par Antoine
Masselier il a continué son
développement aujourd'hui l'entreprise
c'est 5 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires c'est 40 personnes
dans un laboratoire qui fait un millier
de mètres carrés l'implantation du labo
elle est très locale et les employés qui
sont qui travaillent et qui sont
attachés je pense sont tous issus de du
78 c'est les gens qui habitent à 1015 km
donc aujourd'hui délocaliser
l'entreprise déjà ça nous ferait perdre
notre savoir-faire et ça nous ferait
perdre je pense 80% de la main d'oeuvre
implanté à Manille et hameaux depuis ses
débuts l'entreprise compte y rester
nouveau challenge pour la société
élargir son rayonnement économique et
profiter de son positionnement clé sur
le territoire on sent bien que toute la
toute plateaux de Saclay et tout 50 ans
en Yvelines est en train d'exploser donc
nous on est super confiants parce que
d'une part toute cette région là je
pense va se développer dans les dans les
10 ans qui viennent en attendant de
célébrer une nouvelle décennie l'art
Streeter se prépare à fêter son 40e
anniversaire en 2016 avec ses promis un
buffet qui vous fera saliver
et nous continuons sur les métiers de
bouche mais pas tout à fait comme vous
l'entendez cette semaine nous faisons
découvrir un métier d'artisanat original
et pour le moins méconnu prothésiste
dentaire ils mettent leur art au service
de votre sourire nous avons rencontré un
yvelinois qui exerce cette profession et
qui vient d'être sacré Meilleur Ouvrier
de France était lié à peine quelques
semaines Sébastien millasso nous a reçu
dans son laboratoire regardez ces images
signées William elle romarusfini pour le
montage
ces outils ce sont ces pinceaux pas de
roulettes ni d'excavateurs pour
Sébastien millasso il ne fait pas que
fabriquer des prothèses dentaires pour
cet hiver un sourire est un vrai métier
d'art on réalise des tableaux chaque
dent est particulière chaque cas est
particulier et en fait on travaille avec
des poudres en l'occurrence là j'ai une
dent réalisée voilà j'ai une deux trois
quatre cinq poudre différentes c'est pas
c'est pas énorme mais chaque poudre
correspond à une teinte à une couleur et
à une opacité une transparence à 31 ans
cet artisan prothésiste dentaire vient
d'être désigné meilleur ouvrier de
France ils ne sont que 11 élus dans la
discipline un monde au travail lui a été
nécessaire pour atteindre son objectif
on avait une bouche complète
effectivement à réaliser c'était le
sujet avec des contraintes comme je lui
ai dit on avait le sujet de
qui était
réalisé à l'identique de ce qu'on a de
ce côté là une arcade complète des défis
qu'il ne voient pas tous les jours dans
son laboratoire il réalise deux sortes
de prothèses les prothèses adjointes
amovibles comme les dentiers et les
protège conjointe qui elles ne bougent
pas un travail d'artiste qui nécessite
aussi une technique précise quand je
vais mélanger ce pot avec de l'eau que
je vais monter ma dent avec cette poudre
là que je vais la cuire parce que c'est
de la poudre et de l'eau qu'on cuit
allez je vais vous dire simplement dans
les 850 degrés quand ça va ressortir ça
va ressortir exactement comme on le voit
là pour réaliser ce travail Sébastien a
d'abord vu le patient afin de reproduire
sa dent reconnu comme artisan les
prothésistes étaient encore appelés
mécaniciens dentiste jusque dans les
années 70
tout ce qui est fait en prothèse n'est
pas nécessairement artistique puisqu'il
y a plein d'étapes très techniques c'est
ce qui fait la complexité du métier
c'est à dire que on va travailler comme
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure le plâtre
la résine le métal entre 3 et 6 ans
d'études sont nécessaires pour apprendre
à maîtriser ces matériaux les cours sont
dispensés en CFA la pratique en
entreprise là je suis en train de
gratter un petit élément en titane qui
sera vissé sur un implant en bouche je
suis en train de me préparer pour monter
la serra ensuite dessus Quentin est un
ancien apprenti du CFA de Versailles
embauché à la fin de son alternance
celui qui a été élu Meilleur apprenti
d’île-de-france en 2012 ne se destinait
pas à ce métier fait assez patient si
minutieux c'est un travail assez fin on
travaille des beaux matériaux assez
nobles
c'est plutôt intéressant après on va
dire on fait que des dents mais on
redonne un peu le sourire aux gens ça
qui est intéressant et voilà ça me plaît
pas trop pourquoi j'ai mordu dedans en
France ils sont près de 19500 à être
mordu comme Quentin dans ce métier un
jeune obtient rapidement un CDI s'il
commence au SMIC la marge de progression
est importante tant sur le salaire que
sur les responsabilités la profession
est attractive et les laboratoires se
rarifient on en compte 3800 dans
l'Hexagone un chiffre qui a déjà baissé
de 3% depuis 2010
c'est la fin de notre émission merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez-vous la même heure la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
philo un numéro un petit peu plus court
en raison des élections départementales
qui vous pourrez d'ailleurs suivre sur
tes fils 78 il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter une très bonne soirée